[Musique]
c'est dans ce bâtiment historique la
préfecture de saint-denis que les élèves
se sont retrouvés pour la remise des
prix du concours national des flammes de
l'égalité
les thématiques l'histoire des traites
des captures sur la vie des esclaves les
luttes pour l'abolition et surtout leur
héritage contemporain sur les esclaves
bah comment il sait comment ça s'est
passé là-bas m'a parlé d'un esclave noir
qui s'appelle edmond albius non j'ai
appris que aujourd'hui c'est pas fini et
que ya encore un peu de racisme ça sert
à comprendre ce qu'ils vivaient et à
comprendre qu'il ne faut pas toujours
les maltraiter ne faut pas les
maltraiter de vol se ressemble et qu'il
faut pas se battre été comme ça parce
que tout le monde se ressemble et c'est
pas juste à cause d'une couleur de peau
qu'on va mal traiter quelqu'un les
survivances dans les étages contemporain
et aborder les situations contemporaines
avec lucidité ma dignité dans le respect
des autres et grandir en citoyen elles
sont si d'autres finalement cette
période un petit peu
difficile quoique fut l'esclavagé et
comment l'adolescent s'est construite et
quel sens aujourd'hui on va donner à
cette affaire et à cette nation à ce
moment historique
un moment qui va rester gravé dans les
mémoires de ces jeunes surtout cette
année festive des 170 ans de la fête de
la liberté
c'est une année symbolique pour le
département patients effectivement nous
avons comme on aurait récemment les cent
soixante dixième anniversaire de
l'abolition esclavage et aujourd'hui le
départ a effectivement ouvert tous ces
sites je parle ici des haches et des
barres de métal la bibliothèque
départementale lazare et ainsi de suite
et une époque où ces jeunes découvrent
l'histoire de notre île
et ça passe pas effectivement c'est à la
remise des prix chaque lauréat a
présenté sa production théâtre chants
poèmes slam le choix disciplinaire était
important et c'est avec un film que le
collège des mascareignes a remporté le
prix un moyen de mélanger toutes les
disciplines
la chorégraphie a été imaginée et mise
en scène par ma collègue mme adam et eve
propre soeur de ps2 la classe et ensuite
les
le slam a été écrit par les élèves dans
différents contextes
ils ont écrit au musée stella matutina
liaison écrit en classe et il cela leur
permettait véritablement d'être imprégné
finalement de tout de tout le patrimoine
historique que l'on a à la réunion
300 élèves ont ainsi participé à cette
opération
alors faites attention il faut que
chaque enfant chaque personne guerre en
soi une petite flotte et les meilleurs
de toute la france se retrouveront le 10
mai prochain à paris pour la
commémoration officielle de la traite de
l'esclavagé et de leurs abolitions
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]